bienvenue
alors diam's comme carla bruni vous avez
été récompensé aux dernières victoires
de la musique et vous êtes la première
artiste féminine de rap à connaître
succès national puisque en général les
filles font du r'n'b star académicienne
patil
déplacer le rappeuse française
ça le maire est effectivement moi j'ai
la chance d'avoir un
succès cet été est là avec l'album ça
continue eh bien merci
si on a
à peu près c'est pire c'est bien quand
c'est court
quand on vous dit joey starr au féminin
vous agissez comment ça fait plaisir
c'est un grand artiste je vais ça ouais
à la moquerie si vous écoutez diam's
justin j'aime beaucoup vous aimez bien
et vous vous connaissez je connais peu
j'aime
voilà alors en fait que vous êtes donc
la russie et la chine je tenais tout
j'adore
je ne sais quoi ouais je lai chez moi et
mes enfants adorent les enfants sont
très en retard
en fait vous n'êtes ni beurre ni blacks
notamment à ce qu'on pourrait croire un
peu
on avait neuf ans ne sais pas où vous
situez vous êtes d'origine chypriote
exactement elle est née à la capitale de
chypre
j'achète bon nicosie et cosy nicosie le
25 km alternant
jeu s'avère acteurs
vous êtes né à chypre donc à nicosie le
25 juillet 80 rappelons que fumer tue
oui pour ça tous ceux qui sont nés à
nicosie
l'ensemble on a le montage de ce contrat
foot règne pas de faire ce qu'ils
veulent à berne
c'est pas bon pour mon image non je la
garde soit maire de nom
c'est pas mal
la garder les enfants jets de cailloux
il m'appelle jean roucas et très vite
c'est pas ton quotidien alors votre vrai
nom c'est mélanie georgiades est vite
arrivé en france à l'âge de trois ans
avec votre maman votre papa est restée
là bas pourquoi avez vous arrêté d'aller
voir votre père à chypre pour les
vacances
il ya des pères des fois qu'ils n'ont
pas trop compris leurs rôles
bien alors donc vous n'êtes pas peur
comme je les dis vous n'êtes pas non
plus issu des cités vous avez été élevé
par votre mère dans une banlieue
pavillonnaire aux ulis dans l'essonne et
hélas en fait ce dont vous souffrez plus
que de la pauvreté c'est de la solitude
vous avez même pas une bande de potes
comme on a dans les cités quoi vous êtes
tout seul ouais bien sûr un bled on peut
même pas demander du sel à ses voisins
exactement je suis fils unique et c'est
vrai que gênante souffert de ça
maintenant moi je me suis retrouvé avec
avec les mots à la musique mais et je me
suis fait après des amis mais c'est vrai
que j'ai pas trop j'ai comme j'ai pas
mal déménager tout ça j'ai pas eu d'amis
tout ça même pont serait séparables
aujourd'hui j'en ai plein vous avez ça
dure jusqu'à ce que vous découvriez le
rap cette situation là vous commencez à
venir à paris à traîner au forum des
halles et à 15 ans vous rencontrez le
dénommé black mozart ouais et de la
famine ah non non non mais j'ai été
informé oui la première personne à
croire en moi et à me faire des musiques
en fête loué sur lesquels j'ai pu mettre
mais vous deviez quel âge à l'époque
j'avais 15 ans
quand la vous changez vous commencez à
veulent jouer un petit peu c'est là que
vous avez commencé à vous les joies déjà
un peu diva freestyle média web ça n'a
fait qu'accentuer donc exactement vous
donner la bad girls
band girls cependant attitude sûrement
mais moi dans l'attitude c'est tout on
va faire un petit test quel âge le
premier pétard à 11 ans
ça va en quoi bon son le dernier 16
j'arrête vous avez arrêté oui c'est
l'avantagé de commencer je
premier petit copain de 15 ans 13 ans
teint est ce que vous savez quand même
vous a vu de petits copains jusqu'à
maintenant non pas huit cents près
très près combien de petits copains en
même temps vous en souvenez de ce nom un
à un la face à l'homme d'accord les
petites copines
n'est ce pas que vous étiez batgirl vous
êtes auto mutilée ça va arriver way en
tout cas le pantalon
ou fumier combien de paquets de clopes
en une journée à l'époque un toujours un
toujours et là maintenant 1
il ya des gens fuient - 2 wayne et de
sutter raisonnable vous êtes passé une
nuit en taule déjà non
ceci est une vraie bonne garde quand
même à l'époque existerait si vous êtes
tombés en plus sur un bad boy à ceux qui
vous battez ouais je sais pas si c'est
le bad boy mais non c'est même pas un
bad boy en plus parlant avec lui vous
avez 17 ans ouais ouais vous avez jamais
porté plainte pourquoi non parce que
parce que quand j'étais jeune je
trouvais que c'était c'était pas bien de
porter plainte
je suis allé voir les flics bien
évidemment mais il va porter plainte
voilà c'est fait c'est fait vous l'avez
quittée
elle est financée par
votre mère était pas au courant ah bah
non vous avez dit maintenant à bâle a
pas le choix ouais j'en ai fait un titre
dans mon album mais oui et oui ça
s'appelle ma souffrance directement
alors dans votre chanson je trouve que
certaines ma souffrance vous dites loin
de me douter que sur moi il lèverait la
main [ __ ] si j'avais su crois moi je
serai bien loin quand un jour cette
partie bien loin un jour je suis
particulièrement non j'ai essayé en tout
cas de me reconstruire comme on dit
ouais c'est plus ça puis de faire
abstraction de de ce fait et puis
d'avancer pas faire de généralités aussi
parce que ça c'est un petit peu le
problème c'est qu'après on croit que
tous les hommes sont comme ça que moi
font rentrer dans un engrenage mais ça
va je m'en remets à vous avez l'air
ouais alors c'est un album qui est très
autobiographique 1 puis vous ai fait une
chanson sur votre père aussi donc daddy
tu as fait de moi une fille son père
aigri d'avoir vécu dans un couple en
guerre
bref j'en vends mon père c'est normal je
lui en veux parce que je sais que la
base de mon problème c'est lui donc
après si je suis encore c'est tout le
temps ont malgré tout ce qui m'arrive je
sais que c'est de sa faute donc
maintenant je pense que il
il était trop belle pour
toi donc ses parts à pareille en sort
mais vous justin ya un truc et sans dire
dans bouquin c'est que la l'héroïne
louise dit toujours à son père ne me
lasse pas à pas ouais parce qu'elle sait
que c'est ce qui est pire celle inverse
finalement ce qui lui a donné trop de
choses et vous non elle voulait pas trop
gâté elle voulait avoir encore du désir
pour les les choses des rêves c'est
épouvantable et enfants blasé les
adultes aussi d'ailleurs
et puis après il ya ça
[Musique]
alors ça c'est le tube de l'été
évidemment et s'était inspirée d'une
chanson qui existait déjà donc quand
vous l'avez écrite vous doutiez pas et
puis un jour vous entendez ça etc dit
oui c'est vrai ouais on le veut ça
là
mais
obligé de racheter le sample on a
déclaré déclaré donc c'est réglé
maintenant on revient sur cinq dean
martin c'est un classique oui ça a été
chanté par tous les grands crooners
américains dont dean martin
effectivement la décla mais tout va bien
bon d'accord et aujourd'hui à ça c'est
l'attention des cannes là pour le coup
avec sanaa
et la piste de vibrer joker qu'on a reçu
ici avec sa mère exactement et son beau
père noir soit refaite
vous êtes devenu une vraie fille
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus féminine non
oui oui oui on va parler jean bon sinon
la salle vous avez des talons des talons
remporté deux mais j'en ai chez moi
ouais c'est difficile de marché que
telle non j'y arrivais ouais vous dont
du super bien être la vieille cure aussi
voilà ouais ça va doubler ses invités au
restaurant maintenant non ah non non
quand même pas quand même passé quand
même temps dans la salle de bains a le
moins de temps possible ce que je n'aime
pas je pense
voilà vous pleuré quand vous casser un
ongle de faire tout le temps
c'est une vraie femme vous avez peur
d'avoir 40 ans maintenant dans ce
western juste y arriver déjà
avec un paquet de clopes par jour marqué
on n'était pas tous les champagnes à
rien ouais ouais c'est une vraie femme
laura tvo créneau jeu
[Applaudissements]
j'ai déjà vu que j'étais dangereuses
comme une femme au volant devrait dire
dans un morceau saleh oui c'est beau
rêver au prince charmant oui ah oui je
serai commencera chambre voilà dix
ajouté ouais
j'sais pas brillant bah oui d'où le nom
pavaner sur scène avant il doit être
comment voulez le trouvé gentil soit
brillant jeu qu'ils soient cultivés
intéressant quel âge je sais pas 26
quelques hommes
attaquent maintenant vous êtes une vraie
femme vous écoutez abba avec des
bigoudis sur la tête non
géré accepte encore complet à quoi ce
truc là vous voulez combien d'enfants
d'un minimum parce que le minimum mais
je veux pas d'enfant unis alors comme
vous êtes devenu presque une vraie femme
ils ont presque une ménagère de moins de
50 ans une m - 50 comme on dit sur les
chaînes commerciales on vous faire une
interview page de pub vous n'êtes pas
[Musique]
diam's est ce que vous pensez que vous
le valez bien
oui je le vaux bien pourquoi vous levez
vous
pour affronter la vie ouais ouais on va
être un coup de boule
en ce moment vous avez un ami du petit
déjeuner
ouais
des frostis des canucks ouais c'est tout
j'aime bien c'est quoi votre manière
préférée de faire crac-crac
avec une cracotte
ça doit être bien su
profiter de cet écran pub pour dire peu
de citron
dites moi le calcaire c'est votre
affaire non
vous êtes plutôt au zéro tracas zéro
blabla
blabla zéro blabla ouais trop de fracas
qu'est ce qui vous fait rugir de plaisir
l'amour
quand même quand même vous l'avez trouvé
là non
il est excellent
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible